from Miley Cyrus to Jamie Bell celebs  react to President Donald Trump's new  immigration ban president Trump signed  an executive order friday which  prohibits more than a hundred and thirty  million people from entering the United  States and denies entry to all refugees  for 120 days celebrities quickly took to  social media to protest Miley Cyrus  posted this photo of Lady Liberty to  Twitter with text that read stand with  immigrants Alyssa Milano tweeted my best  friend allah mohammed khalid is muslim  his parents were palestinian refugees  his brother is DJ khaled actor jamie  bell weighed in on oscar nominee an  iranian-born director as garfa hardy not  being able to attend the Academy Awards  due to the ban writing quote Oscar  winner Golden Globe winner Cesar winner  listed on Foreign Policy's top 100  global thinkers banned from entering the  u.s. even though the film he directed  the salesman is nominated for best  foreign language film  you